[Musik]
im garten von berlin aus bauma und
seiner langjährigen lebenspartnerin
jeanette sauter herrscht munteres
treiben
es werden stoffe ausgesucht das denen
der einst schuluniformen genäht werden
die togolesische lebensfreude zieht
benny an jeanette ist ihr geboren doch
zu hause fühlt sie sich in der schweiz
vom mut zuversicht positiven denkens und
dem wunsch etwas gutes tun zu wollen
davon handelt dieser film
dollar
[Musik]
anfangs jahr in zürich bei
minustemperaturen treffen sich janet und
benny mit den einwohnern einer
liegenschaft
es ist eine überraschungsparty zum
abschied vom langjährigen hausarzt
beide gehen in pension eine anerkennung
für die geleisteten dienste
doch es gibt noch einen oben drauf
spontan wird eine sammelbox aufgestellt
die mieter spenden für ein schulhaus
projekt von benny des büdericher und
janet es freut mich mit allen ein
bisschen zu feiern und zusammen auf die
schule bell etwa im turbo anzustoßen
das freut mich wirklich sehr
[Musik]
zurück in lohme in der togolesischen
hauptstadt weckten die bewohner im
quartier mit dem morgengebet um den
baufortschritt des schulhauses vor ort
begutachten zu können sind bei den
jeanette nach togo gereist
die ersten acht monate leitete jeanette
die bauarbeiten von zürich aus ihr
telefon schlacht die photonen über meine
ob da wirklich league und schütz und
danach ein telefon zum cross und da hat
1000 tanken und hat gesagt okay alu geht
dass die robuste richtig war tun hat
sind taktik hat mehr kontakt möglich und
zwar viel schicker die geld und energie
wasser der kaufen sich lieber alles
richtig macht und dann hatten wir
natürlich angst vor respekt respekt ja
das ist wichtig da wo kommen die ihr
habt das ist natürlich die mätresse des
[Gelächter]
königs nicht geschafft und da hat sich
riesige darunter electric und dir
bringen der großteil 33 dann mit gewinn
die arbeiten an der decke vor allem das
betonieren hat der pensionierte hauswald
aus sicherheitsgründen selber geleitet
das tor ist es ärgerlich wenn man zehn
mal wieder vor und der nachbarschaft ist
vorbei eine nachbarin und tabak der
marke mit dass es ganz alles neue
die spekulationen zeigen die erwartungen
und die neue quartier schule sind hoch
auch bei jeanette und benny fürs erste
sind sie aber froh dass soweit alles gut
gegangen ist
mehrmals opfer gemacht dass auf der
baustelle nichts passiert einem einmal
mörder kopf wird für die großen sind die
partition das ist die tradition und
bestehen dass da nie passiert meint
wirklich die richtige vision ist es
passiert der webseite das gibt es nicht
[Musik]
wo werden in afrika die weißen genannt
und der judo ist gut beraten sich
chauffieren zu lassen
[Musik]
ja ich mir viel zu ähnlich
wie der firmen vor links und von rechts
und am tag nicht vor allem
[Musik]
die frau die mir geben und mit der ich
bin da die heimat haben
jeanette ist den toten geboren aber
schon vor 50 jahren kam sie als kind
nach europa im thurgau hat sie weder
freunde noch familie hier fühlt sie sich
fremd und nach nur sieben wochen afrika
würde sie am liebsten wieder die koffer
packen
der winter und der schnee sowie mit
meinen freundinnen reden
das fehlt mir bereits aber etwas fehlt
hier kenne ich leute aber es sind keine
freunde
man plaudert nur jeanette hat keinen
tunesischen pass sie ist schweizerin im
herzen und auf dem papier hat mir
verraten dass sie viel lieber golf 4 in
irland machen würde
doch benny zuliebe kamen sie nach togo
den rundungen schrebergarten der
situation ergänzt ich bin natürlich mit
serien
bis heute waren es ferien aber mit der
schule ändert sich das
[Musik]
in ihrem feriendomizil lassen sich janet
und benny bedienen diesen luxus können
sie sich tanja und schaffen jetzt muss
ich das dass sie nicht muss abraham ab
strässer gemeinde und bei harley tor ist
aber mit denen die betriebe mit dem eine
saubere branchen und poet sie sehen da
froh bei mir daraus hätten und nun haben
die beiden stadtzürcher einen wichtigen
termin in solchen fällen immer mit dabei
ist die gute fee schnuckel wie sie
liebevoll von jeanette und benny genannt
wird ist hier zu hause und kennt die
gepflogenheiten ohne solche kontakte ist
man verloren in togo heute treffen sie
sich mit möglichen lehrern
es ist ein bewerbungsgespräch trotz
langer ausbildungszeit sind gute lehrer
in togo mangelware und die schweizer
privatschule könnte die berufliche
perspektive für die lehrer seien aber
noch sind viele fragen offen
jeanette ist das sprachrohr sie spricht
auch tunesischen dialekt jetzt will sie
wissen wie die lehrer den unterricht
gestalten wollen
die stundenpläne sehen vielversprechend
aus
alle waren mit dem gespräch zufrieden
entschieden wurde aber noch nichts
[Musik]
im nächsten tag der grafiker ein plakat
zur baustelle es braucht keine
übersetzungen zu verstehen dass hier
etwas nicht stimmt
[Gelächter]
ein bisschen schlitzohrigkeit gehört mit
dazu
die kehrseite der medaille ist dass man
bei allem genauer hinschauen muss
überall können fallgruben auftauchen
es braucht mut und zuversicht um in
afrika ein bauprojekt durchzuführen
wer schaut zum rechten wenn jeanette und
benny nicht in togo sind das ist die
gretchenfrage und davon hängt der
nachhaltige erfolg der schule ab aber
auch von der anzahl schüler die von den
lehrern noch gefunden werden müssen
nein bekannt dass sich der trend aber
soweit
wir wollen die controller dass es
weitergeht dass das gut funktioniert das
ist auch das werk wird am schluss einmal
der sein dunkles und der eine schweizer
sei mahle schulbau und togo die
baugruppen bis zum schulanfang im
oktober bleibt noch zeit für die
abschlussarbeiten und zeit und schüler
zu finden
[Musik]
mittlerweile ist es oktober richtig wenn
ist udo ist diesmal auch mitgereist er
ist im hintergrund am projekt beteiligt
aber auch sein herz schlägt für afrika
ich bin so entschied aber ich habe auch
großes herz geschlossen
die haut wieder wir sind dagegen habe
das kind in einer qualität hat mir immer
sorgen machen oder was ich machen was
ich übermorgen dann auch eine ratsche
richtig wollte musste und jetzt im alten
bau sind hier bestattet ein für moslems
ein new yorker was übermorgen ist und so
dem schacht versprach oder und ich sage
ich immer planen und das finde ich schön
das ist afrika nicht geplant als dort
nie fotografiert viel und gerne mit den
fotos gestaltete kalender die er
verkauft mit dem erlös wurde die schule
finanziert nein des mpi spielmacher und
standard sieht weiter um sich
andere bis zu 550 franken generiert
in nur einem jahr entstand diese schule
es hat sich gelohnt beim anblick dieser
kindergesichter sind die schlaflosen
nächte und die aufreibenden
telefongespräche vergessen die
zukünftigen schülerinnen und schüler
sind also auch schon gefunden worden
und ein paar wilde locken zwei handys
bewerten
wo es am 15
[Musik]
unterrichtet wird in der landessprache
französisch das schulgeld pro kind
beträgt 50 franken das entspricht einem
durchschnittlichen monatslohn die
während der therapie gebraucht machen
wäre in der großen pause bekommen die
kinder etwas zu essen
drei frauen verdienen sich hier einen
kleinen zustupf eine portion kostet
umgerechnet 5 rappen
das buch das buch dann nur dir wo der
winter dass sie hinter ihnen glücklich
sind ist denn das da hat seine würde
andere aber geht das macht dann arbeiten
wir darüber nach studierte hobbyfotograf
liebt kinder und diese schließen ihn
sofort ins herz welche bekommt eine
riesige auswahl an fotos für den
nächsten kalender
es gibt kein halten mehr 1000 laster
privatschule bellet wohl fühlt sich
immer mehr von 2002 was los gegangen ich
mich um wm in südafrika habe erst am tag
nach der technischen und danke
magnetischen kalender polizist aus wesel
baut man deshalb löst sich das
entwickelt haben dass sie eine
eigendynamik anzufangen eine schule
gebaut
letztes jahr war hier noch nichts und
heute belebten riesige kinder schlafen
rund 2 und schülern die bälle touren
ja sehr
ich bin sehr stolz und es macht mich
glücklich wenn ich die vielen kinder
sehe
ich bin gerührt
ein
hallo
sie trotzen heiße steil war das wirklich
aus
du hast dann heißt es die besten
aufpassen dass der gedanke nicht
eigentlich sehen ein riese hingeguckt
sagte ist noch einiges passieren oder
kapazität dafür der start geglückt sein
doch die nagelprobe folgt erst die
direktorin hat einen doppel auftrag den
schulalltag regeln und die geschäfte mit
jeanette kontrollieren
januar ist die automatische alarm steht
da haben jeden monat garantiert ist das
ist richtig interessant ist
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
und doch ist nachfrage nach spanien dank
[Musik]
das sehen was wir machen
sie wären dann stoßen
[Musik]